everybody and welcome to the unboxing of
this extreme this LG Voyager rubberized
hard case shell so this is the case to
be the first hardware unboxing for you
guys the hardware the case for the LG
Voyager what we're going to do here is I
start my timer I'm just gonna unbox it
and this is just being first the first
initial unboxing video I'll get to a for
review video after iron boxes so here we
go
as you can see extreme PDA ship this
there link will be in the description so
go check that out great product if you
have a sauna you're looking to buy case
they have a great website if you have a
search feature they can search for your
phone so you like so there we go let's
unboxing you shouldn't make you hard
name and nevis and I'm not gonna use
noise cancellation for the exam so
there's background noise of these
unboxings because of the packages but
basically yes it is a hard rubberized
case and here we go except some packing
peanuts but all in all this is the
actual box that the case comes in and a
brief note this sentence so I'm just
going to clean this up and then get to
the first impressions alright we're back
here and I've seen everything off and we
just have to hear the case and I'll
bring in to view the phone so but this
is the extreme PDA case and again the
link is in the description so go check
it out I'm just going to open it up here
and basically what you're advertising is
that this is a hard protective
rubberized case so I'll put it down here
box is really necessary
so they give the front that from the
case looks pretty good and we'll take
the back part out of this plastic here
so right away I notice that the outside
of it is really a hard not not metal but
it's a plastic and then they coat it
with a matte finish so that's very very
cool
we're just going to try the installation
here if I can get it all I'm gonna do is
just clip it all up that's easy
inflation right there so they you they
do give you a advertise that it's a very
clean simple easy installation for the
back part I'm assuming it's about the
same thing I'm just gonna push it down
until I hear a click of some sort and it
should be installed so pushing
hmm see just gonna push it out there we
go I think it's this gold man so I'm
just gonna push down there yeah you
heard that click so that click is
basically how you know that it has been
stalled and what I'm noticing is it does
add a teeny bit of bulk to the front of
the phone it doesn't add any bulk to the
back of the phone it gives you full
access to the camera ok the hard buttons
are still still out and if you don't
know really and much about the hardware
of the LG blazer this is a video
response to the the hardware overview so
go check that out I'm so yeah this does
it is very good build I just it's not
that last part on so that it actually
doesn't have that much built bulk now
that I look at it it does provide full
access to the front ok so that's cool
you do get all access to all the buttons
you open it up it is a hard case um I
really like it I like the look of it
doesn't look like it's gonna be a big
lint grabber okay you do get the
microphone hole there so basically all
the ports you still get access to the
micro SD card you still get access to
very very nice case so if you're
watching this in HD you can pretty much
see the general walkthrough of this case
yeah I really like it so um thanks for
looking at of the unboxing video and we
will get a full complete review in HD
after this so thanks for watching this
unboxing and make sure you subscribe
please